so many people think that money is the
most important thing in the world if
they don't have money they would just
die but that's not true
there's a substance that is far more
precious and far more important to us
that we literally can't live without
what is that care about
love no plenty of people are miserable
and lonely most of their life and and
and live
hair air your air your breath your
breath is the most important thing that
you have the most precious thing if you
didn't take another breath you wouldn't
last three minutes and you'd never get
out of this room and yet we absolutely
take for granted
that our next breath is there look at us
we're all in this room breathing and i'm
not saying don't breathe there's not
enough for me
we assume that it's there
and when we exhale we don't think about
where's my next breath coming from
now
if the power that created us
has given us enough breath to last for
as long as we shall live
can we not begin to trust that the other
things will take care of themselves
see life is here for us life is here to
support us to take care of us to be here
for us the entire planet has been put
here for us to play with
we have everything that we shall ever
need it's already here only we have to
know it and we have to trust it and we
have to acknowledge it
do you realize that there is more food
on this planet than people could
possibly eat
there's an incredible amount of food yes
it is true that there are people
starving
but the food is here
there is more money on this planet than
we know how to count
the money is here now there are lots of
people who are very broke but the money
is here
there are billions
of people on this planet
and yet you will have people tell you
that they're lonely
it has nothing to do with not being
people
it's what we're doing with our heads
everything is here for us for every dis
ease on this planet there is a plant
that will cure it
everything everything is here for us
and the more we begin to trust life
and acknowledge the beauty and
magnificence of our own being the more
we find everything we need it just pops
up
need motivation water top ten with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
louise hay and my take on her top 10
rules for success
enjoy
rule number two do positive affirmations
to begin with you start by
doing what we call doing affirmations
and that is making positive statements
about your life
that
are positive
and you do them deliberately you might
do them in the morning you might do them
at noon you might do them at night
you might do them you know
twice a day or whatever but you do this
and you let this become a habit
and as you start to do them
things will begin to change maybe on a
very small level i call it getting the
green lights and the parking places i
mean they're not huge things in your
life but it can be very nice when you
get three green lights in a row
and you're in a hurry
doing an affirmation is either writing
it down writing it on the wall or the
mirror or using a
you know just saying it what i like
people to do is to stand in front of a
mirror and do their affirmations
because there's something very powerful
about looking in your own eyes
and getting
and accepting yourself or noticing that
you reject yourself when you're saying
something positive about yourself
so that would be a very
beginning way to start
say in the morning you get up in the
morning you go to the mirror and this is
a big one and it's hard for lots of
people
but you look in the mirror and i say and
say i love you
i really really love you
and to begin with that can be so hard
for people because they think of all the
things that they think are wrong with
them but if you can start your day
saying that it's very powerful
remember i'd like to think the universe
is listening to everything you say and
everything you think and saying okay you
can get that
so then it starts to bring you in and
bring things into you
i know this sounds far-fetched but it's
amazing how it works
you if you do a good general positive
statement for yourself
the universe will figure out how to
manifest that
how to bring that about in your life
so things could happen that you wouldn't
expect at all
but they will happen
if you think of doing your positive
affirmations is like planting a seed in
the ground it's not necessarily true at
the moment but it is something you want
to have be true
so you put the seed in
and you you you plant a seed and you
expect it to grow
or you may be plant three seeds just in
case you expect them to grow and you
don't wait for two days and then dig in
the earth and say what's happening
what's happening you expect that thing
to grow because you know there's a law
and a process
and the seed will grow if it is in the
right soil and it has the right amount
of moisture
making it really a habit
and doing it every day
doing something every morning when you
wake up that's a really good time and
another good time is when you go to
sleep at night rule number three watch
your thoughts the thoughts we think and
the words we speak are constantly
shaping our world and our experiences
many of us are in an old habit of
negative thinking and do not realize the
damage we have inflicted upon ourselves
however we are never stuck because we
can always change our thinking
as we learn to consistently choose
positive thoughts the old negative ones
dissolve away
so as you listen to the following power
thoughts
let the affirmations and ideas wash over
your consciousness
your subconscious mind will pick up the
ones that are important to you at the
moment
these concepts are like fertilizing the
soil of your mind
as you absorb them by repetition you are
slowly enriching the very basis of your
garden of life
anything you plant will grow abundantly
i see you vibrant and healthy
surrounded by exquisite beauty
living a life of love and prosperity
filled with joy and laughter
you are on a wonderful pathway of change
and growth
enjoy your trip
[Music]
my healing is already in process
your body knows how to heal itself get
the negative garbage out of the way then
love your body
feed it nourishing foods and beverages
pamper it respect it create an
atmosphere of wellness allow yourself to
heal rule number four take in all of
life lungs have to do with taking in
life
this is the breath of life this is where
we take in life
and we have the ability to take in just
enough to get us by
or we can fill our lungs
and really have all the cells in the
body work well and our brain cells work
well
traditionally for generations and
generations women have been very shallow
breathers because we bought this story
that said we're not good enough that
we're second-class citizens and we began
to believe that we didn't have the right
to take up very much space and we barely
had the right to exist and so we take in
just about enough air to keep us going
that's changing now and it's wonderful
and one of the things that really
excites me today is what's happening
with women in the gyms you know we have
worked in the fields for a very long
time but i think this is the first time
that i'm aware where women have really
gone out for sports and you see some of
the female bodies in the gyms these days
that go out and exercise they are
incredibly magnificent and just
wonderful and they are taking in life
and taking up space and taking air and i
think it's beautiful so people who have
lung problems people who smoke too much
people have emphysema and things like
that they're cutting life off they're
saying on some level i don't deserve to
exist
or only deserve to exist a little bit
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five create better
health if you want to create better
health in your body there are definitely
some things you must not do
you must not get angry at your body for
any reason
anger is another affirmation and it is
telling your body that you hate it or
hate parts of it your cells are very
aware of every thought you have
think of your body as a servant that is
working as hard as it can to keep you in
perfect health no matter how you treat
it
your body knows how to heal itself
if you feed it healthy foods and
beverages and give it exercise and
sufficient sleep and think happy
thoughts then its work is easy the cells
are working in a happy healthy
atmosphere
however if you feed it junk foods and
drink lots of diet soda be a couch
potato and skimp on sleep and are
grouchy and complaining all the time
then the cells in your body are working
at a disadvantage and in a disagreeable
atmosphere
then it's no wonder that your body is
not as healthy as you would like it to
be
you will never create good health by
talking or thinking about your illness
good health comes from love and
appreciation you want to put as much
love into your body as you possibly can
talk to it in loving ways touch and
stroke it in loving ways if there is a
part of your body that is ailing or
diseased then you want to treat it as
you would a sick little child
tell it how much you love it
and that you are doing everything you
can to help it get well quickly
if you are sick
then you want to do more than just go to
the doctor and have him give you a
chemical to take care of the symptom
your body is telling you that something
you are doing is not good for your body
you need to learn more about health the
more you learn the easier it is to take
care of your body
you do not want to choose to feel like a
victim
that just gives your power away
you could go to a health food store and
pick up one of the many good books that
teach you how to keep yourself healthy
you could see a nutritionist and have a
healthy diet created just for you
or you could see a holistic health
practitioner
do create a healthy happy mental
atmosphere
be a willing participant in your own
health plan
i believe we create every so-called
illness in our body the body like
everything else in life is a mirror of
our inner thoughts and beliefs
the body is always talking to us if we
will only take the time to listen rule
number six be grateful gratitude works a
lot
uh if just being grateful for everything
the more
i always say the universe loves
gratitude the more you're grateful for
what
the good is in your life the more good
you get to be grateful about
and it's it's like you know if somebody
gives you a present in your gives me a
present and i say oh my god i hate that
color and it doesn't fit and you know
that person will never give me another
present
but if you say oh it's wonderful and
thank you i really adore it it's great
that person is probably going to want to
buy you a present every time they see
something they think you would like
and it's like that with the universe the
universe loves gratitude rule number
seven trust your inner wisdom i trust my
inner wisdom
there is a place within each of us that
is totally connected with the infinite
wisdom of the universe
in this place lie all the answers to all
the questions you will ever ask
learn to trust your inner self
as i go about my daily affairs i listen
to my own guidance
my intuition is always on my side
i trust it to be there at all times i am
safe rule number eight customize your
future continuous modes of thinking and
speaking produce body behaviors and
postures and eases or dis-eases
the person who has a permanently
scowling face did not produce that by
having joyous loving thoughts
older people's faces and bodies show so
clearly a lifetime of thinking patterns
how will you look when you are elderly
learn to accept that your life is not a
series of random events
but a pathway of awakening
if every day is an awakening you will
never grow old you will just keep
growing
imagine the day you turn 49 as the
infancy of another life a woman today
who reaches the age 50
and remains free of cancer and heart
disease can expect to see her 92nd
birthday
you and only you have the ability to
customize your own life cycle
so change your thinking now and get
going you are here for a very important
reason and all you need is available to
you
you can create thoughts that create a
mental atmosphere that contributes to
illness
or you can choose to think thoughts that
create a healthy atmosphere both within
you and around you rule number nine
believe in the good if you
have very strong beliefs within you that
you don't deserve good things in your
life
and a lot of people have that then there
can be delays
and sometimes people say well
affirmations don't work i've done them
but when they're doing for instance
prosperity affirmations and they've done
some prosperity affirmations they say it
doesn't work nothing's happening and i
say well all right how many prosperity
affirmations did you do in a day and
they'll say three probably and they say
all right how many poverty affirmations
did you do this day
and that could be 300 depending on where
you're coming from and what are is
running through your mind
see i have this one of my thoughts about
life is that only good lies before me
and i've been saying this for many years
so it doesn't really matter to me
what happens in life because i know it's
going to be good and rule number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is trust the process of life i am
deeply fulfilled by all that i do
we will never have the opportunity to
live this day again so we want to savor
every moment
there is richness and fullness in
everything we do
each moment of the day is special to me
as i follow my higher instincts and
listen to my heart
i am at peace in my world and affairs
i trust the process of life
we are learning how life works it's like
learning your computer when you first
get a computer you learn the simple
basic processes how to turn it on and
off and how to open and save a document
how to print and on that level your
computer works wonders for you
and yet there is so much more that it
can do for you when you learn more of
its ways
it's the same thing with life the more
we learn how it works the more wonders
it performs for us
there is a rhythm and flow to life and i
am part of it
life supports me and brings me only good
and positive experiences
i trust the process of life to bring me
my highest good
[Music]
resentment
is a pattern that
eats away at the body
and becomes cancer resentment and anger
are very different angers
and you scream and yell like a baby
babies get angry
instantly and they yell and streak and
then they're through and two minutes
later their smiles will just light up a
room
because they've gotten it out what we do
is we take offense
at somebody for having done something
that we created to begin with
because we're all 100 responsible and we
don't do anything about it and we put it
down in here and we start to let it
seethe and it boils and it eats away at
us and if we have it long enough we can
create cancer
see diseases like arthritis are created
from things of patterns of criticism
arthritic people are always very very
critical people now they may be sweet on
the outside but that means that the
criticism is turned inward and they're
doing a constant
negative put down number on themselves
now i know that you've heard me say many
times or you've read or
listened on the tapes that loving
yourself
is the most powerful thing we can do
then everything flows
everything flows beautifully i'm not
talking about
vanity or arrogance because that is not
love that's always fear
i'm talking about just really respecting
and appreciating this incredible
magnificent being that we are
you know little babies know how to love
themselves you were born in pure love
all of you there's not one little baby
alive i that i know of that ever
criticizes its body or ever says my hips
are too big have you ever heard a baby
say that
they're just thrilled and delighted that
they have a body
they rejoice in it and they love
themselves they love their toes they
love everything about themselves they
absolutely adore
they
express their feelings you know when a
baby is happy you know it when a baby is
angry the whole neighborhood knows it
they're never scared to let people know
how they feel they live in the moment
and they're filled with courage
and they're wonderful and we were all
like that
got to remember that you were filled
with courage and you were full of love
and you adored yourself when you were
very little i think that everything you
think and everything you speak goes out
from you into the universe and comes
back to you multiplied uh it's almost as
though the universe is listening to
everything you say and everything you
think and saying oh that's what they
want you're saying there's a quality of
life doesn't mean a really nice house or
a really nice it can but it doesn't have
to but what good is a nice car if you
are full of resentment all the time and
you
drive around hating everybody that's not
going to help anything it's much better
if you had an old car and you were
grateful and appreciative of life one of
the things that i think about
the work that i do and the work our
company does is that every product that
we sell or that probably that you get as
a gift from us uh has the possibility to
change the quality of your life to
improve the quality of your life now
whether you actually take that
opportunity or not is up to you that's
freedom but you have everything we give
out can help people really improve the
quality of their lives and that feels
good when we have a problem most of us
go oh panic panic god what are we going
to do
but i have something that i try to get
people to say when the minute there's a
problem you stop and you go all is well
all is well everything's working out for
my highest good and out of this
experience only good will come
and i am safe
and you do this
if it's a small thing i say it two or
three times if it's a bigger issue i
babble it incessantly but all is well
everything is working out for my highest
good out of this situation only good
will come and i am safe
now this gives
this quiets your inner turmoil down long
enough for the universe to find the
solution to the so-called problem see
when there's problems we don't have to
fix problems so much we need to fix our
thinking
and our attitude about how we respond to
them
and then you get less and less and when
when the solution comes you say thank
you i want you to just they can connect
with you exactly
i want you to think back to
that memory if it feels safe to do so
and how do you see that memory now is it
do you feel tension in your body is it a
picture you see is it just something you
remember
well it's a feeling it's a feeling it's
a feeling okay and what's the feeling
well it's a
feeling of fear
it's not the terror that it was but it
it's still there because you know the
child is very helpless in that point
yeah
and can't really do anything to get out
of it it's a
trapped situation
and where do you feel that fear in your
body
oh in here okay very much i say thank
you many many many times of the day
often not to anyone else i just you know
oh thank you that's so wonderful thank
you
and it's uh you know you find more and
more things to be thankful about we were
i was driving up today from san diego
and the
wildflowers on the hillsides are just
beautiful this year and i was thinking i
was so glad that i had the opportunity
to see them
because if i stayed down there i
wouldn't have but this drive which was
you know not a drive i particularly
wanted to make but it was gorgeous the
simple part
that most people don't understand is
that every thought we think in every
word we speak
is creating our future
it's as though our thoughts go out into
the universe and are
accepted and brought back to us as
experience
now that is a very simple thing but most
people don't get it they don't
understand it they've never heard it
before and they think it's ridiculous
but if you can really accept the fact
that every time you think a thought and
every time you speak a word you are
literally painting your future making
your dinner whatever you want to call it
you are creating
and you're creating your own life
and this is simple
but it's not easy
to accept but once you accept it then
you can start deliberately
creating what you want in your life
and you begin to be aware
of what you don't want in your life and
how you are contributing to it
now i think this has been around forever
but for some reason in the last 20 years
the universe has wanted this to go out
among all the people or all the people
that are ready for it
see most of us just think they think
think think think think and we don't pay
any attention to what we're thinking
we're just doing it but that's something
you need to train yourself to do to
begin to train yourself to be aware of
what you're thinking
and and one of the ways to do that is to
periodically say to yourself what am i
thinking
would i like this thought to create my
life
would i like to have the experience that
this thought could bring to me
now it takes a while to do that but even
if we could begin on the smallest level
to be aware of our thinking we can start
to make changes in the work they can go
and tap on those issues so sort of
combine both together you do the mirror
work it brings up the things that are
bubbling or maybe you can even tap in
front of the mirror maybe that'll be the
next innovation and tap and say
affirmations in front of the mirror you
know yes
yes so do you want to do a little
tapping sure you know for for the for
the crowd so
i know we did a little there you had a
little neck pain the last couple days so
we did some tapping but we could always
do a little more yeah
so how how deep do you want to go
well how do
you want to take me
so let's for for people who weren't with
us private last couple sessions let's
talk about the neck pain and what was
going on and
and our conversation it started as some
spasms yes it started as some spasms
that wouldn't go away
and i was feeling tremendous pressure
back here and down my neck
and
i realized that this went back to a time
when i was five years old and um my
stepfather used to hold my head under
water and he had his thumb in that
particular place
and
my thought was for some reason it's time
for me to let this go
and the thing is how to find out how to
do it when life calls us
that's when we have to answer
people say how did you do everything
that you did well i
answered the telephone and opened the
mail
and did what it what was in front of me
and then life would give me something
else to do and something else to do
and it's interesting because it's now
been i think 25 years since i wrote the
second book you can heal your life
and in that period of time
i that book alone has sold
40 million copies worldwide
[Applause]
and i feel i've always felt that i
didn't do anything to promote it at all
it's just life took over and life said
this book is going to go to this country
and this book is going to go to this
country and go to this country
and
it's gone
many many places all over the world i
even have two chinese versions
there's the chinese version of uh
traditional china and then there's the
chinese version of the taiwan which is
the new china
you never know where life is going to
take your work
and i think that it's important that you
don't go into it to say how much money
can i make oh i'm going to be rich i've
got to do this because books don't make
you that rich
but what they do is open the world to
you
and my thought has always been how can i
help the people how can i help the
people gratitude works a lot
if just being grateful for everything
the more
i always say the universe loves
gratitude the more you're grateful for
what
the good is in your life the more good
you get to be grateful about
and it's it's like you know somebody
gives you a present in your or gives me
a present and i say oh my god i hate
that color and it doesn't fit and you
know
that person will never give me another
present
but if you say oh it's wonderful and
thank you i really adore it it's great
that person is probably going to want to
buy you a present every time they see
something they think you would like
and it's like that with the universe the
universe loves gratitude for those of
people that have tried to change their
thinking but seem to be stuck and can
you give them some advice to help them
to be more positive or to get through
well i don't think that they've been
trying and they're stuck i think they
just haven't tried because if you will
practice this even a small amount it
makes a difference i have a simple
exercise i give everybody and some
people say oh that's so stupid it's so
silly but i ask them to look in the
mirror especially first thing in the
morning and just look in their eyes and
say their name
and say i love you i really really love
you
and this is enormously hard for most
people to do to begin with but as you
continue to do it it makes a big
difference
you see life loves you life really loves
you but if you don't love yourself
it's very hard for life to bring you the
goodies because you've got this wall up
so when you can learn to love who you
are and that's the way you were born
when you were a little tiny baby and
when i say you i mean everybody
listening to this
we all adored ourselves we loved our
bodies we loved every part of ourselves
and then we started to listen to other
people who told us we weren't good
enough or we didn't do it right or no no
no and so we decided that maybe we
weren't very good
and that's where we get all mixed up but
when we can get back to that point of
just adoring this marvelous critter in
here
then life says oh they've she's got it
she's got it let's give her goodies and
then the next step is to be very
grateful about it yes when you're really
grateful then they want to give you more
when i work with people when i workshops
or classes or anything i always try to
get people just to open their arms so
that we can let the new and remember
this is the subconscious mind and this
is where we're holding
so this is saying nothing new will get
in so i always like to feel that i'm
open and receptive to new ideas and i'm
willing to learn and i'm willing to
change and i'm willing to grow and
sometimes i don't want to and sometimes
it hits areas that i don't really care
to change at the moment and you know
that's always an area that i know is
important for me to work on to me i
think enlightenment is
letting go of all the things we believe
that are not
benefiting us us in life or there are
barriers to our life to the good things
in life and to release them one by one
and to think
i don't have to believe that anymore
or do i want to believe that anymore and
making a conscious choice when we can
understand that every single thing we
believe has been a choice
and it
may or may not be true it can be true
for you and not for you
because it's your belief system and your
belief system and then i have my belief
system i say a lot
that may be true for you it's not true
for me i may not say that out loud but
people are doing things they're saying
things and i think that to myself a lot
and also it has nothing to do with me
whatever's going that has nothing to do
with me because i'm under the law of my
own consciousness
this is my pathway and you have your
pathway you have yours everybody does
so we're all on a journey and i think
the more conscientious we are about it
and the more conscious choices we make
the better our journey is or the easier
or the swifter or that we get more
goodies or we have better health
if you
have very strong beliefs within you that
you don't deserve good things in your
life
and a lot of people have that then there
can be delays
and sometimes people say well
affirmations don't work i've done them
but when they're doing for instance
prosperity affirmations and they've done
some prosperity affirmations and they
say it doesn't work nothing's happening
and i say well all right how many
prosperity affirmations did you do in a
day and they'll say three probably and
they say all right how many poverty
affirmations did you do this day
and that could be 300 depending on where
you're coming from and what are is
running through your mind
see i have this one of my thoughts about
life is that only good lies before me
and i've been saying this for many years
so it doesn't really matter to me
what happens in life because i know it's
going to be good remember little tiny
babies when they're born they absolutely
adore themselves
and they're totally open and they're
full of love
they express themselves freely they ask
for what they want
they love their bodies from the top of
the toe to the top of their head to the
tip of their toes and every point in
between including their own feces which
they'll gladly rub all over their bodies
because nobody's taught them guilt and
shame
they know how wonderful they are
and then somewhere along the line we get
this idea that we're not good enough and
we start putting our tape tape measures
around our waistline to tell us if we're
acceptable
or we read magazines that say we have to
be a certain height or a certain weight
before we're acceptable or we listen to
the media that says we have to use a
certain deodorant before we're
acceptable
you know it just doesn't make sense
we are absolutely divine magnificent
expressions of life all of us and like
when we were in the circle looking at
each other we each face is another
unique expression of god and we're not
supposed to be alike
since time began on this planet there
have not been two snowflakes alike
and there's certainly not been two
people alike
and we're always trying to be like
everybody else so we're acceptable our
uniqueness is what makes us wonderful
so we want to love that and cherish it
and acknowledge it you see if we really
believe in our uniqueness and the wonder
of each being then there is no
competition and no comparison there
can't be we're just different and we're
meant to be different and that's
wonderful every single
thought we have or every sentence we
speak is an affirmation
and it's either positive or negative and
it's going out from us and it's creating
our experiences
however when we talk about doing
affirmations what we're talking about
is
making
definite positive statements to create
something in our life or to remove
something in our life you see if you
stand there and say i don't want this
job or i don't want this relationship or
i don't want these hips or i don't want
whatever that does not get you what you
want
that's what i call fighting the negative
and it doesn't do anything but keep what
you have that you say you don't want
however if you start saying and doing
affirmations that i have a wonderful new
job
or i have this most absolutely marvelous
relationship then you're beginning to
create what it is you do want
affirmations are like planting seeds
and if you think for a moment when you
put a seed in the ground you do not get
instant tomato plant or instant
strawberries or instant oak tree
that seed goes in the ground and it has
to germinate
that's the first thing which means it
breaks open its little shell and little
roots begin to go down
and it gets nourishment from the earth
and only then
does the first little shoot come up
through the ground
now when we're doing affirmations too
often people say well that isn't a
million dollars and they stomp on that
first little shoot
they don't give it a chance to grow
doing affirmations is like planting a
seed in the ground and watering is it it
is like repeating your affirmations and
you just keep doing them and you keep
doing them and you keep doing them
and it doesn't matter whether you see
the results or you don't see the results
and
sometimes it just takes time and too
many people will do affirmations for two
or three days and say see it doesn't
work
you know if
everything happens in the perfect time
space sequence and we want to trust that
and we want to know that so if you begin
to do affirmations for yourself
and i think it's important that we do
that on a daily basis decide what you
want
and begin to do positive statements in
present tense for what you want you
never want to say i will have or i'm
going to have because if you do that it
keeps it in the future and remember
if you say i have a wonderful new
apartment and you're living in a dump it
doesn't mean that this is not a true
statement it means you are planting the
seed that will germinate and grow and
become the new apartment i think we get
we all get certain ahas
and that's when we sort of learn
something we say oh okay and then if we
can keep that
what we've learned and practice it
then we've made another step and we can
move forward
um
yes it's a lifetime journey and we never
stop learning
i'm 80 and i'm still learning
though the lessons are easier now than
they used to be i like to think of that
when we start we have all these boulders
in front of us on our pathway and we
start to get the boulders out of the way
and you finally get to the point where
it's gravel
and gravel you can handle
you know and you can sweep gravel and
you can do things
so
and then occasionally there's an old
boulder
that rolls back into your bed
you think oh i thought i i thought i had
that one
but not
completely
and and you know also i think that when
we learn lessons we think oh i've
learned that one it'll never happen
again i've done that and that's it
well how do you know you've done it
unless it comes by once more and see how
you react
have you really learned it is it really
nothing for you have you gone beyond
that or are you going to go right back
into the same old reaction
see we're never wrong
that's what we need to learn that we're
always doing the best we can with the
understanding and awareness and
knowledge we have at that moment if
you're in a job you don't like if you're
in a relationship you don't like if
you're in a a house you don't like
and you want something new begin to
bless with love
interesting to bless with love
where you are
and and know that you're releasing your
current situation with love if it's a
job release it with love to the next
person who will be delighted to have it
if it's an apartment do the same thing
if it's a relationship release that
person with love to happiness which is
meaningful to them
and that leaves you free to create and
accept happiness that is meaningful to
you you say you have to start with
beginning to love yourself i think you
hear a lot of that in the 80s and what
the what does that mean it means to stop
putting yourself down stop criticizing
yourself stop mistreating yourself begin
to treat yourself as something that's
very precious
and when you begin to love who you are
then you can love your neighbor because
you love yourself you see i don't think
we can really love our neighbor till we
do love ourselves if it is true that
your thoughts shape your life
would you want what you were just
thinking right now to become true for
you if it's a thought of worry or anger
or hurt or revenge or fear
how do you think this thought will come
back to you
if you hear yourself expressing negative
words of any sort stop in mid-sentence
either rephrase the sentence or just
drop it
you could even say to it out you get to
choose any and all thoughts you wish
these thoughts create your future
experiences
let us stay away from thoughts that
create problems and pain some of you
know my little blue book and the fact
that i've been doing a lot of work with
this ease for a long time
and for every part of the body there is
a mental pattern
and for every dis ease in the body there
is a mental pattern and when you know
what they are you can begin to change
the mental patterns
so that
you can change the dis-ease you see we
don't want to be sick no that's a
blanket statement sometimes people do
want to be sick because it's a good way
to get out of something
the rest of us know how to say no
if you don't know how to say no you may
have to create an illness in order to
say no
because that's we've made in society
we've made that a legitimate way of of
getting out of things
but basically we do not want to be ill
and yet we need every dis ease that we
have
because it is the body's way of telling
us
that there is a false idea in
consciousness
something that we're doing something
that we're believing something that
we're saying is not
for our highest good
and the body is saying please
and it's sort of almost like tugging
saying pay attention
so
when we know what these patterns are
it gives us again a choice of whether we
wish to do something about it or not
there are lots of things you can do to
help you become more conscious of what
is going on and because so many of our
belief systems really are unconscious or
subconscious we're not aware of them
they're just things that were bred into
us as we were children
uh is to
take a little time to figure out what
they are and i always say a really good
exercise is to take a big sheet of paper
and write on top of it say what i think
about men and then another one what i
think about women what do i think about
uh money what do i think about any
subject you can think of
and just write all the things that come
down come out of your thoughts
and whether they sound good or not just
write them down
and
any one subject if you just write them
all down and then look at them and see
how many are positive and how many are
negative
and if you can take those negative ones
and turn them around make them into
positive affirmations then you can start
clearing up what you believe about say
money that is not positive for you
and or is keeping you from bringing
money in
uh and and you can do that with lots of
things in your life so you can really
begin to realize what you do believe
about these things
so you can't change your thoughts if you
don't know what your thoughts are
there is a law of thinking and we are
beginning to learn about it and it is
like a computer if you have this
gorgeous computer put in front of you
and you don't know what to do with it
it's a piece of junk
but if you learn the language of the
computer
miracles happen
and that is what the law of thinking is
when you learn how it works
miracles happen
what you think
and what you believe is what will come
true for you your thoughts create your
life
it's that simple and when we can get
that we can make enormous changes is
stopped scaring yourself
how often do you terrorize yourself
with your own thoughts
you're getting to absolute terror and
it's only coming from your thoughts
nobody out there is doing a thing
sometimes it's an old family pattern
sometimes we get new things
i would like people when you have time
to make a list of your fears
make a list of your fears
and then give yourself the opportunity
to turn each fear
into a positive affirmation
turn each one into something positive
and remember always you are in charge
you are always in charge
[Music]
see one idle thought
doesn't make a whole lot of difference
thoughts are like drops of water
you drop a drop of water and it doesn't
mean much but if you keep dropping and
keep dropping you get puddle on the
floor
and then you can get a little pond and a
lake and finally you can create an ocean
and with our own thoughts we can drown
in a sea of negativity
or we can float on the ocean of life
and it's up to us
the thoughts we think accumulate
and what sort of puddles are you
standing in or are you up to here or are
you up to here and trying to paddle
now what are you doing to yourself
when we're willing to change our
thinking
we can change our experiences
and it doesn't matter if you've got a
big
puddle of negative thoughts you know you
can move over here and create a puddle
of mindfulness positive thoughts you can
make changes always
so you want to turn those fear thoughts
into positive affirmations
let them work for you i have a thing
when i was seeing people that i got to
the point where i would not see anyone
who did not make their own appointment
i have found occasionally people have
sent people to me as a present oh you
must go see louise here i'll give it to
you as a present
every one of those has turned out to be
a disaster
half the time the people didn't turn up
when they did turn up they weren't
really interested when they seemed to be
interested they never went away and did
anything or if they did it was a little
bit and they never came back
we have to be ready to do it ourself
remember each person has come to this
planet to learn a lesson you have your
lessons you have your lessons i have my
lessons you have your lessons they're
all different
we cannot learn the other person's
lessons we are not here to change other
people we are here to change ourself
that is what we've come to the planet
for to change ourselves
if we try to
do it for someone else or learn their
lesson or make it nice
they don't get to learn it
and even if we fix it isn't it amazing
how they turn around and recreate it
again and we all know people like that
we've paid their rent or we've gotten
them out of some mess or we've done this
for them or that for
and two months later they're in the same
problem because it's their pattern
it has nothing to do
teaching them how to get out of it it is
much better if they're willing to learn
so it's like you know the student must
come to the teacher and when the student
is ready the teacher is there always i
think it really starts with realizing
that you don't love yourself that most
people don't most people feel they're
not good enough they haven't done it
right they won't do it right they'll
never be enough and they're definitely
not lovable and when we come from that
space
it's very hard to create things for
ourselves that are really good
so
in the early days when i worked with
people i used to
fix this problem and fix that problem
and you'd have this a health thing and
we'd work on that and we'd work on this
and one day i discovered much to my
amazement that if i would help people
learn to love themselves to really
accept themselves as they are we didn't
have to work around problems because it
was almost like a miracle everything
seemed to fall away it's a hard one for
people because we're
we grow up believing that we're not good
enough and nothing is right
i remember lots of times i would ask
people well what is really wrong with
you what have you done that is so
terrible that you're not acceptable to
yourself and i never ever ever got an
answer that made any sense you know they
might say something like well i'm too
fat well
so
you know
but
i
when you talk about loving yourself a
lot of people think that that's vanity
but it isn't really it has nothing to do
with that
that is narcissistic but to really care
for you and to acknowledge that you are
an important being it's almost like in
the bible they would say
you recognize that you are a child of
god that therefore you are perfect but
even if you're not a biblical person if
you can recognize that you are a being
that has self-worth if you can really
recognize your own worth then you start
to treat yourself differently and i
think that's what's so very important
about loving yourself is you stop
beating yourself up you stop making
yourself wrong you stop talking about
how awful you are and you stop saying
things like i'm really stupid and stuff
and you start to treat yourself with a
certain amount of respect and this makes
an enormous difference because what you
give out in life is what comes back to
you
so if you're giving out a feeling of i'm
okay i'm good enough as i am and i am
acceptable and i love life and i love me
and you start having gratitude for
yourself and for life then life treats
you differently because you are having a
different vibration that you're giving
out and getting back
and that's when things really start to
flow now a lot of people don't realize
it but you have to practice you just
have to start it and that's why i try to
get people to do a lot of mirror work if
you look in the mirror just simple
things like looking in the mirror in
your own eyes and saying i love you i
really really love you and it helps if
you use your name louise i love you i
really love you it gets to that little
child inside that has been rejected for
so long and it breaks open sort of a dam
or a door or whatever you want to call
it and it's like
little miracles start to happen lots of
little good things happen
and the universe loves grateful people
the more grateful you are the more you
get to be grateful about people think
that prosperity is just money but really
there's many many other things that come
under this auspices of prosperity
you know you can be very poor in time if
you feel really rushed all the time and
always pressured you have poverty in
your time but if you feel that you have
all the time in the world and that
whatever you want to finish you'll get
done and it will it will all happen then
you're really prosperous in time
and what about success you know if you
feel that it's really way beyond your
reach
then you're never going to get it
but if you feel that you can be
successful whatever that means to you
then that's wonderful that's prosperity
wisdom do you have prosperity and wisdom
do you feel that all the wisdom in the
universe is available to you or do you
think oh i'm just me and i don't know
very much
and you know i can't figure things out
if you feel that you're really connected
with the universe and you really trust
that part of you that's inside then you
can be absolutely prosperous in the
abundance of wisdom
and what about love
do you feel that you i have an abundance
of love
or are you very poor in love is there
very just a little bit of it in your
life
how about joy
do you feel you're really prosperous and
i have an abundance of joy or is that
something you just allow yourself a
little bit of now and then
and you really are very poor in joy
and then what about beauty do you see
beauty everywhere
you allow yourself to experience an
abundance of beauty
and of course there's money then there's
money too
you know what do you let yourself have i
like to use that uh image a lot of the
ocean standing in front of the ocean
with a container in your hand you know
and you're there and you have this
container but what is it
is it a thimble with a hole in it is it
a small cracked cup
is it a mug
is it a vase
but no matter how much you have whatever
your container it is and no matter how
much you're taking from the ocean of
life and even though we're all standing
there we're not robbing each other and
there's plenty for everyone and no
matter how much we take there is no way
we're going to run that ocean drive it's
absolutely possible
and if you can see yourself standing at
the ocean of life in the same way
and remember the container that you have
is your consciousness
and you can always change your
consciousness
and it doesn't matter if you came from
poverty it doesn't matter where you came
from it doesn't even matter what your
parents believes were because it's your
consciousness and what you're choosing
to think to believe about prosperity and
your ability to deserve it
is what's going to create it for you i
want you to say to yourself your name
i love you
i really really love you
i love you
i really
really love you it's a new thing you
probably haven't done it before but what
we're really trying to do is to connect
with the inner child within who has been
neglected for so very long
most of us when we look in a mirror we
criticize ourselves we make fun of
ourselves we say
derogatory things to ourselves it's a
habit
and what we want you to do
is to start
connecting with that inner child within
you that wants so much to be loved
and hasn't been for perhaps years and
years and years and years and maybe
never when it was a child
[Music]
i know this is a tough one to stay but
if it's too tough to start with you can
start with something like
louise i'm willing to learn to like you
[Music]
not quite so threatening
so i want you to this is something i
want you to do
a lot first thing in the morning i want
you to get in the habit of having your
little mirror with you whipping it out
at any time or anytime you pass a mirror
say something nice to yourself
i i will look at myself and say you look
fantastic kid and sometimes i'll say you
know you may not be as tight and taut as
you used to be
but you're fabulous you're absolutely
wonderful we want to be our own
cheerleader we want the things that we
say to ourselves support us and love us
and make us feel good or make us feel
silly
you know you're a hot potato
and it's not only just
saying you love yourself but do your
affirmations into in front of the mirror
do forgiveness in front of a mirror if
you have somebody you need to forgive do
it in front of a mirror and have get
yourself if you have a big mirror sit
down in front of it because you won't
run away you can't it's too hard to get
up
and you can sit there and you can cry
but you'll go through it whatever it is
and it'll be fast
the mirror as small as this may be
can really help you connect with
yourself looking in the mirror and
saying how can i make you happy what can
i do to make you happy today if you want
more top 10 videos they're not on this
channel anymore i have a dedicated
channel just for it go check it out the
link is right there next to me continue
to believe and i'll see you there